[Musica]
ciao a tutti mi sentite
bene so che mi sto presentando in modo
un po insolito ma c'è un motivo
e durante questo talk capirete perché ho
deciso di non svelarvi subito
oggi scopriremo insieme
l'importanza che ricopre l'oralità nella
comunicazione umana e l'impatto che
questa genera nelle nostre esperienze
sociali online
buonasera sono laura caro leo e studio
nuovi mezzi di comunicazione e come
queste influiscano e plasmino la società
in cui viviamo
sapete quanti siamo
sapete quanti siamo sul nostro pianeta
siamo circa 8 miliardi di persone in
italia poco più di 60 milioni
e oltre il 58 per cento della
popolazione mondiale è più del 71 di
quella italiana utilizza i social media
infatti è grazie i nostri device se ci è
stato permesso
durante gli ultimi anni di
distanziamento fisico di colmare il
vuoto di una socialità persa così prima
per curiosità e poi per ricerca ho
iniziato a utilizzare a studiare tutte
quelle app che sfruttano la voce come
metodo principale di comunicazione
qualcuno di voi qui in sala mai
utilizzato apcom e club house twitter
space dischord o parla con i propri
amici durante una sessione di red gaming
alzate la mano
perfetto grazie
dovete sapere che la prima
caratteristica che sin da subito
attirato la mia attenzione relativa ai
social migliorali riguarda l'aspetto
della moderazione
sin dall avventura i social media
tradizionali facebook per intenderci
ci siamo fatti educare
sospendere
consigliare da algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale a volte anche di dubbia
intelligenza come suggerisce una parte
della letteratura scientifica che sono
figli di pregiudizio di errori mai data
7 di chili addestrati
questo non vuol dire che siamo
finalmente liberi dai buyers dei
pregiudizi perché perché le piattaforme
orali
invece le piattaforme ora li mettono al
centro l'uomo
a moderare lì non è più l'algoritmo a
moderare e l'uomo questo non vuol dire
che siamo liberi dai buyers dei
pregiudizi al go ritmici anche l'uomo
come la storia ci insegna può essere
paralizzato o popolarizzare orientando
opinioni idee azioni in un'unica
direzione
ma grazie alle piattaforme ora li
abbiamo riscoperto lagorai del mondo
antico dove l'arte oratoria il confronto
ponevano le basi del vivere comune in
società ci ritroviamo in un agorà
digitale
dove l'uomo per un momento torna al
centro è l'algoritmo esce di scena
ma la seconda cosa la seconda
caratteristica che veramente mi ha
spinto studiare le piattaforme orali è
che uno degli strumenti di comunicazione
più potenti che l'uomo abbia a
disposizione è la voce
attraverso la voce rispettano chat
scritta un'immagine non riusciamo a
percepire molto di più del nostro
interlocutore ad esempio se vogliono
chiudere gli occhi e mi ascolta ste
riuscireste a percepire interpretare più
o meno la mia età il mio genere
il mio sesso e potreste anche dedurre e
ipotizzare delle mie caratteristiche
personali magari anche intellettive beh
cos'è questo è un emoticon e che cosa
indica indica uno stato di imbarazzo
mentre con quest'altro indichiamo uno
stato di felicità
per poter comunicare le emozioni
nelle nostre interazioni online ci siamo
dovuti inventare un nuovo insieme di
caratteri cosa che invece attraverso
l'utilizzo delle piattaforme orali
ora non succede più perché grazie alla
nostra voce possiamo anche comunicare le
emozioni
vi ricordate questo film hard di spike
jones
in questo film theodore si innamora
della voce di samantha l'intelligenza
artificiale che lui stesso stava
addestrando qui il rapporto è
interamente basato su una comunicazione
orale attraverso la voce i due
protagonisti comunicano emozioni e
sentimenti ma perché vi ho fatto questo
esempio perché quello che accade nei
film accade anche nella realtà l'altro
giorno mi è stato detto ho pianto tutta
la notte per un uomo col quale parlo da
mesi che non ho mai visto ma che credo
di amare beh i social migliorali stanno
bonificando il paradigma della
comunicazione online mettendo un po
tutto sottosopra non sono incentrati
sulle estetica sull'immagine sul
consenso di un laico di un cuoricino
sono piattaforme corali che mettono
insieme persone che altrimenti non
avrebbero mai potuto conversare tra di
loro e in più anche il nostro rapporto
che il device cambia distogliamo lo
sguardo dalla dallo schermo togliamo le
mani dalla tastiera e ci concentriamo
esclusivamente sulla voce
ma
qual è il vero perché sono così
importanti queste piattaforme
perché non solo mettono in connessione
persone che non si sarebbero mai potute
incontrare tra di loro ma anche perché
li danno ai social media quello che era
il loro scopo iniziale ovvero utilizzare
uno spazio digitale per creare una
comunità
consapevole e solidale
ma come funzionano queste piattaforme
diciamo che come se fossimo in una
chiamata
a più voci voi potete decidere se
ascoltare o semplicemente possa
interagire con le persone che sono
all'interno di queste piattaforme
queste piattaforme ci sono delle stanze
o degli spazi dove si parla della
qualunque dalla politica allo sport la
letteratura la televisione potete
persino ascoltare la rassegna stampa
mattutina
oppure potete accedervi semplicemente
per parlare con voci che ormai sono
diventati familiari
ora vi porterò alcuni esempi su come
queste piattaforme possono avere delle
ricadute positive sulla nostra società
sul nostro stare insieme
ho visto e ossa anzi ho sentito
giovani della generazione z e boomers
confrontarsi sui più disparati argomenti
con l'unico obiettivo di creare
un argomento comune e di contaminarsi
posso farvi l'esempio di un'anziana
signora molto intelligente che superata
la soglia degli 80 anni per via di una
pesante solitudine entrata in
depressione
il figlio le ha fatto scoprire una di
queste piattaforme
lei agli inizi si connetteva dicendo era
da giorni che non parlavo con qualcuno
ora è un'assidua frequentatrice si
connette quasi ogni giorno ed è
diventata bravissimo utilizzare l'app
beh grazie alle voci che per lei sono
diventate amiche esce dal suo stato di
isolamento e solitudine
altro esempio positivo una giovane donna
che affetta da una malattia autoimmune è
impossibilitata uscire di casa e quindi
ogni sera accede in una di queste
piattaforme si ritrova in queste stanze
con persone che per lei ormai sono
diventate care in un salotto virtuale e
quindi si sente nelle sonata
ma le piattaforme ora li possono avere
delle ricadute positive non solo sui
singoli anche sui gruppi di persone
vengono utilizzate da moltissimi ciechi
che hanno le loro room o anche diane
semi di riposo dai ris agli anziani
delle case di riposo
c'è un volontario che ogni giorno per
lumia per dare la parola agli anziani
nelle case di riposo
questo momento è uno dei momenti più
felici della loro giornata finalmente si
sentono vivi finalmente si sentono parte
della comunità ed escono dal loro stato
di isolamento
tutto questo non sarebbe mai stato
possibile con le piattaforme
tradizionali che per loro natura sono
asincrone e non permettono una
interazione profonda come solo la voce
umana e come solo un dialogo umano in
tempo reale può dare ah dimenticavo
attraverso le piattaforme orali voi
mostrate chi siete
ciò che sapete non si può fingere
io non so
e neanche voi qui noi non sappiamo che
cosa ci riserverà il futuro dei social
media
ma una cosa ho capito
che dobbiamo che dobbiamo utilizzare i
social media in un determinato tipo di
modo il modo in cui noi la utilizziamo
fa sì che anche gli altri
riescano
a utilizzarli in un modo migliore ho
anche imparato che si può tornare a
essere meno eco riferiti che si può
guardare oltre un filtro di instagram
che si può tornare a utilizzare una
dimensione digitale per creare una
comunità
per pensare e per parlare agli altri
e per tirare fuori il meglio che c'è in
noi attraverso l'utilizzo delle nuove
tecnologie
[Applauso]
[Musica]